CNN is trying to ban the term fake news
law President Trump has called for a
fake news trophy and an Obama holdover
left-wing deep state stooge is trying to
subvert democracy and take over an
executive agency the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau in these fake news
awards aren't we all the real winners
yes we are then Amanda presto Giacomo
and awesome and super sang joined the
panel of deplorable x' to discuss a
groundbreaking new study out of Yale
that shows indulging ridiculous
fantasies makes you more left-wing who
would have thought Susan Sarandon and
John McCain's telling Hillary Clinton to
STFU I'll let you spell that out and
Denzel Washington drops racist eight
facts about personal responsibility and
the family
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
Happy Holidays there are so many
holidays that happened in the last 4
days we had Thanksgiving we had Black
Friday we had evacuation Day everyone
forgets that holiday but it's a great
one and I promise you I drank in your
stead in lower Manhattan on it and Cyber
Monday
it's Cyber Monday is a great day the
main reason it's a great day is because
it lets me hock my products and that
would be reasons to vote for Democrats a
comprehensive guide this is the blank
book that started it all
that really intervened in my life in a
very positive way President Trump is
endorsed it as a great book for your
reading enjoyment none other than mr.
ben shapiro calls it thorough dennis
prager read it twice the it goes on and
on Michelle Malkin said Michael Knowles
perfectly documents what's inside the
minds of Democrats a real page-turner
this covers every major topic and gives
all of the reasons to vote for Democrats
in a total of 250 pages and about 11
words you've got to go out there in
order it right now this is the
indispensable stocking stuffer you know
this could be the main gift for any
Democrat in your life family friend
relative you have to go get it reasons
to vote for Democrats I really hope this
get this wins the Pulitzer this year and
that the National Book Award but we
can't do it without your help so spread
the knowledge and and instruct your
friends and relatives on real political
philosophy okay we have a lot of fake
news to get to today one thing that I'm
thankful for we didn't go over this what
do you thankful for at the Thanksgiving
episode I'm really thankful for
president Trump's Twitter account it's
one of the highlights of my news
consumption all year he sent out this
beauty this morning quote we should have
a contest as to which of the network's
plus CNN but not including Fox is the
most dishonest corrupt and or distorted
in its political coverage of your
favorite president me they are all bad
win or to receive the fake news trophy
so here is CNN fake news outlet par
excellence CNN's brian Stelter
discussing the fake news it's time to
retire the term fake news that's what my
next guest says
Claire Wartell is the executive director
of first draft it's a non-profit
research group a base of the Harvard
Shorenstein Center Claire we've talked
about this before I want to share with
our viewers if we never use the term
fake news again what should we say
instead so we should think about what
we're actually talking about so I'll be
talking about misinformation they're
just mistakes that people make are we
talking about disinformation when people
are actually trying to cause harm and
they are disseminating false information
or we have Mal information genuine
information that shared again to cause
harm so that could be revenge porn it
could be a leaked email so we just need
to be much more specific about what
we're talking about is that because
President Trump and others have co-opted
the term fake news and basically
redefined it so to reason spazzy a lot
of stuff isn't news and secondly it's
been co-opted by politicians around the
world as a label for things that they
don't like and it's being used as a
weapon against organizations like CNN
and others and so when it's been used as
a weapon against the news industry and
it's just being co-opted we have to
think much more carefully about the
power of language and it's damaging oh
is it
it's damaging to yoyo is a grail you're
using it against right-wing outlets but
now that they're using against us we
have to stop by the way all three
versions of thick news that she said CNN
does all of them so but now they want to
now they want to ban them because they
either are being disingenuous or they
don't get the point the they want to be
on the term they're the ones who created
the term the term fake news reached a
mass audience people forget this it
reached a mass audience for the first
time in the days following Donald
Trump's election victory when a
left-wing college professor named
Melissa Zim DARS published a viral
Google Doc listing a bunch of
conservative news outlets including our
own including the Daily wire as quote
fake news the irony though the irony of
which we pointed out is that while
outlets like The Daily wire and others
are honest about our point of view you
know where we're coming from we're not
pretending to be somebody we're not
places like CNN lie about their
political slant all the time they
pretended objectivity they they often
spread outright false stories you know
they do fake news here what are some
other examples MSNBC ran a fake Morning
Joe show on Friday it was pre-taped they
pretended it was live the New York Times
man reporting on the alleged
Trump Russia collusion was shown to be
entirely false it was so false actually
that former FBI director James Comey
both said that the story wasn't true
also on alleged Trump Russia collusion
CNN that brian Stelter x' network was
forced not only to retract a story but
to fire an entire reporting team over
over false reporting over a bad story
according to a media Research Center
study 91% of mainstream news coverage of
Donald Trump has been negative according
to Pew Research Center Trump has
received more negative coverage not only
than Democrats like Obama and Clinton
even more than george w bush according
to another study the majority of
Americans believe that mainstream news
coverage of Donald Trump is too negative
and we're not just talking about the
facts of the stories it's not like the
majority of Americans say stop running
reality it's more which which stories
are being run which stories are being
harped on which stories are being
completely ignored or their harp done
for Republicans but ignored for
Democrats double standards if the
Democrats didn't have double standards
that have no standards at all the fake
news trophy though we can't give it to
brian Stelter we can't give it to Jim
Acosta we can't give it to Jake Tapper
we can't give it to any of those guys
the fake news Trophy winner this month
it has to go to Leandre English she is
the Obama holdover bureaucrat who is now
she's pretending to be the new director
of the Consumer Financial Protection
Bureau a particularly unaccountable
government agency that shouldn't exist
in the first place and was established
by senator Elizabeth Warren of the
Massachusetts tribe over Mick Mulvaney
the actual director named by President
Donald Trump for comment let's turn to
Senator Warren
[Music]
I have not I have not senator Warren I
don't know why you would ask me CFPB
director Richard Cordray and Obama hold
over just resigned and he appointed
Leandra English another obama bureaucrat
as the director of the agency so far so
good
only trouble is he has no authority to
do that and so president trump named
budget director Mick Mulvaney to run the
agency nevertheless the Democrats they
love just playing pretend especially in
government so the woman is just
pretending to be the director of this
this unaccountable agency now on his
first day by the way Mulvaney brought
dunkin donuts to the office so i think
we know who is going to go for him win
hearts and minds but Ali and ringless
I'm sure was waiting for somebody else
to bring her doughnuts she's entitled to
them obviously and back to the agency
the agents she shouldn't exist the
agency was proposed by Elizabeth Warren
before she became a senator 2007-2008 it
was authorized by the dodd-frank
permanent financial cronyism Act of 2010
the agency's major accomplishments in
its seven years of existence appear to
have been enriching trial lawyers and
abusing black employees one unit was
nicknamed the plantation because it
comprised all black employees and was
subject to a special abuse specific
abuse one employee called it a quote
humiliating experience said working for
the CFPB is quote a living hell
it's apparently run by intimidation and
like a dictatorship there are
consequences for disagreeing or
disobeying the king all of their words
not mine according to a Government
Accountability Office report one-quarter
25% of minority employees of the CFPB
reported that they have been victims of
discrimination almost 1 in 10 employees
reported that they had been retaliated
against by a supervisor for calling
attention to the discrimination now none
of this is surprising by the way because
this is one of the major problems baked
into the agency this the the agency is
unaccountable it's an independent agency
Denis shawl there's a former aide to
Barney Frank that that's the law that
created the agency dodd-frank he
explained in an op-ed for the Wall
Street Journal last week that the CFPB
should just be shut down which it should
the see if
Phoebe is uniquely unaccountable he
writes it's an independent agency with a
sole director he who direct er isn't
even accountable to the congressional
appropriations process so there are some
independent agencies like the Securities
and Exchange Commission the FCC the FTC
those are funded by Congress but the
CFPB is funded by the Federal Reserve so
that means it has precisely zero
congressional oversight
Shaul assails the position of CFPB chief
as quote a politically biased regulatory
dictator and a political stepping stone
for its sole director that is true as
directors now running for governor of
god-knows-where as an independent agency
the CFPB is supposed to be bipartisan
but while a lot of its employees donated
to Hillary Clinton 2016 not a single one
of them donated to president Trump's
campaign now what about the agency
itself what is it done the CFPB has been
useless and duplicative of other
services as you might expect it took
credit for other agencies and
corporations work like when the LA Times
uncovered fraud at Wells Fargo it
illegally as regulated industries
outside of its mandate it pays
significantly higher salaries and other
agencies that's how it got so bloated so
quickly it maintains a slush fund of
billions of dollars because its finances
lack any oversight and it's proposed
rules which luckily Congress intervened
to overrule would have devastated
industries even the CFPB's name is
propaganda wins a it's a Protection
Bureau Dodge Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau and the nice
regulatory Bureau government Bureau that
just doesn't have the same ring to it
now the agency is even pretending that a
left-wing stooge is its director rather
than the presidential a appointed one
that's because as President Reagan
pointed out one of the many bits of
brilliance he's bestowed on us a
government Bureau is the nearest thing
to eternal life on earth now the CFPB is
particularly egregiously unaccountable
it embodies everything that's wrong with
big government bureaucrats and so on
this is another holiday this will be the
the fake news trophy day congratulations
to the fake consumer financial fake
Protection Bureau interim director a
fake director Leandra English you win
this month's fake news trophy now we'll
have to bring on our panel to talk about
this but first do you know how I knew it
was time to bring on the panel Marshall
do you know do you how how did I know
that it was time to bring on our panel
there it is baby the movement watch
that's how I know because I am a semi
serious person at least so I wear a
watch I have at least two places that I
have to be every day one of them is at
the cigar bar down the street and the
other one is here to do this show so how
do I keep my schedule in order I keep a
watch so I at least don't miss my
appointments movement watches is it's at
this great company they've totally
disrupted the watch industry they have
sold so far 1 million watches to
customers in 160 plus countries around
the world
it has solidified itself as the world's
fastest growing watch company now the
way they do this if you go into a
department store you want to get a watch
like this it could cost you 400 $500 but
movement skips all of that because they
give it direct to you online so you know
that they were founded on the belief
that style shouldn't break the bank and
they want to change the way that
consumers think about fashion now by the
way buying a watch it's not is that big
a deal especially when when prices like
this make it accessible to people these
watches started just 95 dollars so what
you should do is buy multiple watches
you know you can wear movement watches
with just about anything they have a new
lineup so I really like this one this is
the white chrono 40 millimeter I really
like this but they just like the day I
ordered it they came out with a new line
called the revolver line and I really
want to get one of those watches too so
if these watches were 500 bucks I
couldn't do that I'd have to sell many
more blank books fortunately they're
they started under $100 so I think I'll
probably just get another one holiday
shopping can be very tough thanks to
movement all of that anxiety can
disappear with just the press of a
button you know I'm sure you've got
yourself a watch but you can finish your
holiday shopping and and get a moving
watch for somebody on your list that it
goes really well with blank books so you
can whatever you've already bought from
this all show so far you should get this
for your loved ones you know they're
really they're just really nice very
sleek very minimalist and it's such
great prices you should get them for
anybody on your list
so the great news is this christmas came
early for you folks evacuation day came
like christmas came early 15% off today
but only for my listeners with free
shipping and free returns if you go to
what is it
movement calm MVM t.com / co FFA MVM
t.com / co FFA co v fe f e the watch has
a great design it makes a great fashion
statement now is the time to step up
your watch game don't wait until later
run do not walk so that you can type in
the greatest promo code in the history
of reads mbm g calm / co f fa c OV e f e
fe enjoying the movement panel thank you
for being here and you should i highly
recommend you both go out and get
movement watches we have a so we assume
sang and we have amanda press to Giacomo
also in should we get rid on should we
get rid of the Consumer Financial
Protection Bureau
honestly I don't particularly care right
now it's it's a situation but what I'm
more interested in is reporter honestly
is the drama that you alluded to it
began the show going on right now it's
really really funny how Nene and Miss
English as you were talking about the
top of this show right now warring for
the top stop the top spot and control
over the staff of the CFPB and it looks
like this is going to be tied up
potentially in court for at least a
little while but there seems to be a
serious actual fight for control of the
CF it sounds like the worst job in the
world why are these people fighting for
it it seemed who would ever wanna be
said of the CSP V president Trump
himself could solve this right now by
nominating someone to be a permanent
head of the CFPB but they don't seem
inclined to do that at the moment it's
just a very funny almost bizarre
situation perhaps doing so would
acknowledge that this is something to
which you would need to appoint a
prominent head exactly and as the Trump
administration has been very quiet about
their position is probably very similar
to yours that this is something that
should 100% beyond the federal chopping
block yeah absolutely
that is what I think it is he cuz he
could just nominate someone right now I
love the idea of Mick Mulvaney who is
the budget director who famously said
that the the Bureau shouldn't exist at
all and I do like the idea of him
strolling in there with Dunkin Donuts
and kicking out this woman who's
pretending that she has the job but it
will be tied up in courts for a bit I
think even left-wing lawyers and legal
scholars are saying clearly the
president has the right to name his
person it might be a weird quirk of the
law that there is this loophole right
now but that it probably won't stand up
in court but my question for Amanda is
why does the left love unaccountable
bureaucracies so much yeah I mean they
just love the control and power it's
just part of the the leftist ideology so
the more bureaucracy they have the more
people are dependent on government the
more the government grows there's more
control they just they love it they love
these intricacies in this bureaucracy
that holds everything up so this is just
like a product of what they are and I
agree with you I think we should get rid
of it chopping block for sure it's hard
because I think most people don't know
anything about the CFPB so they hear a
consumer protection that seems good I'd
like consumer protection but what does
consumer protection what is the the
bureau really done they almost created a
brand new industry for trial lawyers and
it doesn't seem that protect consumers
terribly much do you disagree Asselin
well before I get to that I would like
to address what you were saying earlier
about unaccountable bureaucracies I mean
uh we could spend the entire day going
down the list both on the left of the
right but I think it's just a function
of whoever's in power that they like
unaccountable for accuracy's sometimes
in the form of waging war overseas so I
really don't think that is a exclusively
liberal you think you don't think you
know you don't think that the left is
more inclined toward bureaucracy
obviously look President Bush set up the
Department of Homeland Security after
the United States was attacked and a
major act of war but nevertheless that's
true President Reagan wasn't able to cut
the government wasn't able to kill off
bureaucracies but you don't think that
it's more of a twitch of the left to
expand government to expand government
power and in the case of the CFPB to
explain
I do explain unaccountable government
power that doesn't have congressional
oversight it honestly really depends
which corners of the federal government
you're talking about I mean I really do
believe but you you would say that the
left is in terms of in terms of
financial regulation which is what we're
talking about right now of course that
is more of a tick of the left that's a
thing they think that's you just think
that the the right is more prone to
military strength and so they'll grow
the government in that sector uh well
again I really don't think that's
exclusive to either the Republican or
Democratic Party is you were talking
about if we want to talk about Bush era
abuses and eye expansion the Obama
administration certainly was not very
very passively political left shall we
say in terms of rolling a lot of those
back so I get worried about painting
these into exclusively left or right but
perhaps not and it's it's I think it's
fair enough to point out that the Bush
administration expanded the federal
government in many ways Medicare Part D
for instance and Barack Obama while
perhaps holding a coherent foreign
policy nevertheless kept us in
Afghanistan for a long time
the vast majority of deaths in
Afghanistan occurred under his watch
nevertheless even though they're
imperfect actors here is is it not fair
to say Amanda that government expansion
per se is a greater facet of leftism
than it is of any conservative
philosophy in in modern America yeah
definitely I mean I could see the
argument for national security reasons
where the right might expand bureaucracy
in that sense but aside from that I mean
it's clearly that's a tick of the left
and in almost any other area besides
maybe national security plus I also have
TSA PreCheck now so I've been the main
Bush era expansion I've been I haven't
been groped by a long time as we've seen
the Trump administration has been doing
a phenomenal job of shrinking the
government when it comes weaponizing the
Department of Justice to go under after
undocumented families they didn't dig
down
undocumented you mean you mean illegal
aliens resigning of the in the country
you mean that he's enforcing the law
through his Justice Department but the
euphemism you used was weaponizing an
agency to go after undocumented families
but consider the language of that phrase
there are people here who have broken
the law and the law enforcement agency
is now finally holding up the law
because we were a nation of laws not a
nation simply of men what's so bad about
that are you asking me or the other
panel that's you well in terms of
enforcing the law I mean do you really
think the Obama administration and this
is what the Obama was the administration
was actually hit repeatedly by
immigration activists on the left for
ramping up deportation I mean you don't
by the way you don't mean immigration
activists you mean illegal immigration
activists well people who think as as I
do as long as we're talking about
political preferences opinion you said
the top of the show you're very upfront
about your political views I'll do the
same with mine people who wish there was
something closer to an open borders
policy for people who think a larger
level of immigration is better they're
lower level of immigration in this by
the way I I don't mean to cut you off
but I want to hear your opinion in light
of this news story because this leads
perfectly into the the main news story I
want to bring on and by the way I
appreciate your being honest about your
political views but more than that I
appreciate that you have come on to show
it is so hard to get lefties and
Democrats to come on this show I truly
appreciate it and I mean I look I love
political debate wise Barretts and like
cool you and I go way back I like you
well this is the here's the news story
from dear old Yale researchers a dear
old Yale are now claiming to have cured
conservatism professor John Barr writes
in The Washington Post quote no one had
ever turned to conservatives into
liberals until we did before
conservatives answered survey questions
we had them engaged in an intense
imagination exercise they were asked to
close their eyes and richly imagine
being visited by a genie who granted
them a superpower if they imagined being
completely physically safe
the Republicans became significantly
more liberal so if conservatives in
other words if conservatives are
instructed to indulge in ridiculous
fantasies they become more left-wing
which makes perfect sense to me now a
Saone to you and please continue on your
previous thread as well these professors
appear to be treating conservatism as a
strange psychological glitch rather than
as a coherent political philosophy or or
set of philosophies now we're all just
pulsing nerve endings according to this
idea we have little conscious control is
the left in this case denying the
rational faculties of everybody or just
of irrational conservatives I would
honestly I wish I had a copy of that
study you're referring to and from me I
have not read it I'm not familiar with
the authors you're talking about and I'm
not familiar with the methodology or
where they're coming from and I'm not I
don't feel incredibly comfortable way in
a studied I haven't read it oh sure sure
sure but your macro question is that
there is a lot of people in American
liberalism or even farther than that on
the American political spectrum who seek
conservatism as a disease that's what
you're getting at right yes
there's certainly and again I hate
playing this both sides thing but I mean
there certainly you wouldn't disagree
with me that there certainly is no
shortage of that on the American
political right in far right like I
think saying liberalism is a cancer or
disease if we googled around for that
I'm sure you'd find plenty of
conservative commentators you know and
probably enjoy and respect who go around
saying in fact uh I will make one
distinction though because we have heard
we have heard versions of this like
feminism is cancer or whatever you know
you hear these things but the
distinction is I think by saying that
leftism is a disease or cancer you might
say that and say that it's really bad
for the country and we should convince
people to stop thinking those things and
become conservatives but to say that
it's a psychological glitch which i
think is what these people are getting
at at Yale and I think
what a lot of people on the Left have
said for a while I think is what the
field of political psychology is largely
based on to say that it's just a
psychological glitch is to deny our
faculties of reason it's to preclude
reasoned argument so whereas we might
have a debate over whether whether
leftism is a cancer on the American body
politic if we accept their premises what
their premises are saying is that we
can't have any debate at all because
we've arrived at our conclusions not by
recent thought or discourse but because
you know our brain made us do it
and they twitched in a certain way
Amanda if wishes were fishes we'd all
swim in riches and if ifs and buts were
candy and nuts we'd all have a Merry
Christmas
given the absurdity of the premise of
this survey is there anything worthwhile
in the results could there be no I mean
from what I gathered from the Washington
Post piece in the write-up we did at
daly warrior basically if you just end
up here if you're granted this power by
a magical genie that nothing you're
impervious to any consequences of these
policies then yeah you'll think like a
liberal so it it kind of proves the
opposite that if you have a rational
mind and you're aware of consequences
and you're aware of safety risks for
instance they're talking about
immigration then yeah you're going to
side on the right because there are real
risks and by the way they were talking
about immigration and if you look
broad-based there are a lot of people
it's a clear majority who want to put
some sort of clamps on immigration I
think it was like 79 percent and I think
it's like 30 percent of those who are
pulled won't even come out and publicly
say that they want to halt immigration
so this is like a big issue across
America it's not just people on the
right so just altogether the study was
really really ridiculous
but as a Nadira sometimes I think it was
this amazing providential moment that
when this show launched Yale was at the
center of just every crazy lefty thing
in the country because they they might
have convinced a few people in that
study but not me everybody now we have
much more to talk about we I know you
want to hear more from a so and I know
you want to hear more from
and but you can't do it unless you go to
the Daily wire calm right now if you're
already a subscriber thank you very much
you keep cook that Faye in my mug if not
you got to go over there we got to keep
the lights on for some I think we even
pay Marshall I've been advocating
against this since the beginning but I
think we do don't we such an outrage no
justice in the world if you go to daily
wire calm right now what do you get you
get no ads on the website that's pretty
nice you get me get the Indra Clavin
show you get the Ben Shapiro show yeah
yeah yeah yeah but here it is here it is
folks the leftist tears tumblr President
Trump today referred to Elizabeth Warren
as Pocahontas during a press conference
with Navajo American veterans of World
War two they are going to be pouring out
from the ceiling leftist tears here it's
already happening all over Twitter and
the cfpb fight is going to result in a
deluge of salty and delicious leftist
years so you have to go to daily wire
calm right now have them hot or cold
always salty and delicious we will be
right back
the left of Lennon actress Susan
Sarandon and sort of Republican Hilary
pal John McCain are both telling Hillary
Clinton to STFU
those are McCain's words and they're not
mine he said quote one of the almost
irresistible impulses you have when you
lose is to somehow justify why you lost
and how you were mistreated I did the
right thing I did the hardest thing to
do is to just shut up what's the effing
point keep the fight up you've got to
move on Susan Sarandon seems to agree
and for her part she's still defending
her vote against Hillary Clinton
instead for Jill Stein Amanda I actually
don't really care about the Hillary
angle of this anymore but I do love the
personal responsibility aspect because
there is no crying in politics and yet
the Democrats are still crying over the
2000 election they're still crying over
2016 why are Democrats in particular
always making excuses for their
political failures yeah I mean it
it's the party with no personal
responsibility we see this in their
politics as well and it's obviously
transcended through Hillary I mean she's
been on this tour since she lost and
it's personally I hope she keeps it up
and I hope she runs in 2020 but you know
it hurts their party overall and it's
just a kind of a symptom of of how they
view the world like it was someone
else's fault it wasn't it wasn't her
fault it wasn't a bad campaign it wasn't
that she skip states at you know what
would have should have campaigned in
wasn't that was a terrible campaigner
that she couldn't relate that she lied
that she was a criminal knows there's
somebody else's fault it was those darn
Macedonian content farmers remember the
heck she was there such an imposing
foursome you know yeah it's never within
themselves so it's it's not good for the
party but I'm I'm all for it so I hope
she just keeps coming out here and keeps
going with it as when this brings me to
a Thanksgiving related question it was
just angry giving a big difference
between the right and the left to me it
appears seems that the right values
personal responsibility more places a
greater nfident emphasis on it when we
speak when we explain our vision of the
world while the left insists on
grievance and entitlement the victim
mentality the ever blossoming and
flowering intersectional
hierarchy of victims and I'm not even
talking about strategic messaging with
Obama blaming obstructionist
congressional Republicans or Trump
blaming obstructionist congressional
Republicans while they're in office I'm
talking about Hillary Clinton Al Gore
these people are out of office
is there a gratitude deficit among our
friends on the left well to directly
address Hillary Clinton for a moment
because there's a lot to unpack in what
you just said there when any Republican
or Democratic presidential candidate
loses there is a period of mourning
sometimes it lasts longer than others
Mitt Romney certainly had a I'm likable
tore after he failed to defeat Oh Barack
Obama into 2012 uh but with Hillary
Clinton I think for her personally and
from what I've gathered talking to
people going in and out of her inner
circle during and after the 2016
campaign is that this was a particularly
hard blow for her to absorb in large
part because this had been something
she'd been working up to since Nadia
decades and to lose to someone who seats
she saw as so unqualified and so vulgar
and so demagogic as Donald Trump who
many people including those in her inner
circle was telling her would be
essentially a cakewalk to defeat in a
general election it's for her it has
been something incredibly hard to get
over but she I noticed I mean sure Mitt
Romney went on his likable tour he
started speaking about politics a little
bit more during the 2016 presidential
cycle but he basically disappeared he
would give a couple speeches he showed
up to the White House to shake hands
with Barack Obama but when you look at
George HW Bush when he lost in 92 he
basically just disappeared and kept his
mouth shut
same thing Bob Dole same thing with John
McCain he went back to work Mitt Romney
disappeared for a good while
but these Democrats who have lost
Gore and Hillary Clinton blame everybody
on their mother for their defeat and
then keep harping about political issues
over which they have little control as
as law losing candidates well the thing
with the Clintons is that since the
1990s for better or for worse they have
essentially been the center of power or
at least one way or another the center
of gravity of the redefined Democratic
Party in the wake of its electoral
failures post Reagan is right so I think
a big part of the reason why she isn't
going away as a lot of people including
a lot of people on the left and center
left would like to her to go away is
because she is trying to continue to
define herself as a player in the
Democratic Party hmm and to do that you
have to sustain irrelevance and right
now she happens to be doing that in
terms of the book tour to not only
establish ongoing commentary and
relevance but to try to tell people her
side of what went wrong and why I am NOT
currently a leader of the free world
with Al Gore I mean if my memory serves
he did obviously complain about the
incredibly narrow 22,000 word demanded a
recount
right but pretty soon after that after
Bush became president he spent a pretty
solid period of time redefining in self
as a client changing as the savior of
the world
you could look in the mirror in the
morning stuff I'm sure you didn't
appreciate but it wasn't um
complaining about the election in twenty
four-seven per se he did have a form of
moving off if you can win an Oscar and a
Nobel Peace Prize for a largely
inaccurate PowerPoint presentation I
appreciate that more power to you go
with God I wish it were me and you and
you make an excellent point to which is
that the Democrats in the wake of
especially Donald Trump are running on
rage the pink hats and the resistance
they've named the opposition to trump
after the opposition to Nazis they're
running on rage and she's trying to tap
into that and it's very funny for me to
watch especially as her third cousin
once removed now speaking of personal
responsibility Denzel Washington dropped
some truly bigoted hate facts over the
weekend while he was promoting his new
film Roman J is real Esquire Denzel said
that researching the LA Criminal Court
system for the movie did not make him
place more blame on the system or the
prison industrial complex or alleged
systemic inequality for problems in the
black community instead he blames oh my
gosh runaway fathers he blames
individuals who make bad choices he said
quote it starts at home I can't blame
the system it starts with how you raise
your children if a young man doesn't
have a father figure he'll go and find a
father figure and what doesn't washings
and I actually share the same acting
teacher decades apart and it seems that
we share the same opinions too though I
don't know how he can possibly keep
working after making such bigoted and
terrible and factually accurate comments
as he did Assuan almost oh we lost Aspen
but we'll get him back hopefully he'll
come back Amanda that this is actually
the direct question I have with this how
does Denzel get away with contradicting
Hollywood left his door thaad oxy yeah I
don't know but he has he's made comments
like this before and for some reason he
just stays in the game maybe maybe it's
an identity thing I'm not sure but I
love Denzel and and what he said was
exactly right but yeah for some reason
he can he can make these comments and
then keep working and he's also a
fantastic guy he's a tremendous actor is
one of the the few left who's really
prominent who is just an excellent
properly trained you know he brings so
much to every role in their different
roles as when almost three-quarters of
black children are born out of wedlock
in the United States so is Denzel right
or the problems in the black community
cultural primarily or are they primarily
the result of some systemic racism well
if you I'm sorry my connection cut out
so I can only imagine that we're
dropping hints left and right
yeah all right gotcha gotcha ah the
comments he made in the they were
printed the New York Daily News that's
right about it starting with the family
hmm
well denzel washington if you know much
about his at least public political
leanings there isn't too much shocking
about him saying that I mean he
identifies as a political independent
yes he supported Barack Obama but he's
never been a raging leftist in his
public persona Hollywood standards used
to the right of Attila the Hun all right
yeah maybe a little bit more centrist
than that uh but but he did what he said
actually reminded me a lot of something
Spike Lee has said multiple times and
Spike Lee is certainly way more to the
left and politically outspoken than mr.
Washington when there were issues of
police brutality being talked about by
black lives matters activist Spike Lee
was actually pretty firm in saying that
yes there is police brutality but we as
the black community or black communities
across the United States have to look
more inward onto ourselves instead of
just always blaming to police and he was
actually dragged quite a bit for that so
when I read what Denzel Washington said
it actually struck me as kind of of
course that's what stands out Washington
would say uh a lot of famous
african-american individuals across the
political line across the political
spectrum yeah yeah was it wasn't too
shocking a culture war to me like I
think his his quote was a very brief and
it didn't have much political context he
was simply saying that it starts at home
it that raise your children right I
don't think there are many people who
disagree with that sentiment it just
grew I think you would never find a
white liberal ever say that ever once I
think they would be run out of town on a
rail and I think that for the white
liberals in their paternalism they need
to say that people don't have any agency
over their own lives they don't have any
cognitive faculties or faculties of
determination and perseverance rather
you don't have a shot in this country
and you're just being kept down by some
invisible force so don't even try and
apparently I'll disagree
hang out with I I think you and I hang
out with different types of white
liberals baby I don't know I don't know
man New York la vieille try hanging out
with nation liberal sometimes maybe
that's its basis listen if nobody could
be more irrational than then these
lefties out here in Hollywood are
constantly preaching their nonsense so
yeah maybe that's a demographic we'll
just have to bring on more speaking of
Asian liberals that I enjoy soup saying
thank you for being here as when soup
saying excellent commentary we
appreciate you and we want to have you
back Amanda pressing the Daily wire is
very on great to have you here and I'm
Michael Knowles that's the Michael
Knowles show that's our whole post five
holiday show congratulations on the fake
news trophy winners we will be back
tomorrow so join us and we'll do it all
again
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Marshall Benson executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey supervising producer
Mathis Glover our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex's and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Cora Mina hair
and makeup is by Jeshua alvera the
Michael nul show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2017